ce serait que nous sommes tous tombés amoureux de
Quicksilver dans le dernier film et nous
voulions trouver un moyen unique et
intéressant de retirer ses pouvoirs d'aller à l'
extraction, le manoir implose donc
j'essaie de faire sortir tout le monde,
nous utilisons certains des plus
technologie de tournage sophistiquée pour créer cette
séquence très très élaborée, nous utilisons un fantôme
pour le ralenti la caméra fantôme
tourne à 3 000 images par seconde afin qu'elle puisse
geler en temps réel et pour mettre cela en
perspective quelque chose qui se passe
en un clin d'œil tourne  en environ
15 secondes afin d'obtenir le bon timing,
nous espérons déplacer notre caméra à
près de 90 miles par heure alors qu'elle
traverse l'explosion des effets
visuels, il y a tellement plus d'éléments maintenant que
tout est gelé et ils volent à
travers le  air les vrais défis
leur sécurité vient d'atterrir à
proximité les uns des autres les gars ont
répété pendant la majeure partie de la semaine et
je pense que nous sommes prêts à y aller on y va
trois deux un aller
vous